So here's another story.
A while back I heard a story about
some music tests that were being run,
and it was for an interface for
a washing machine or something.
And there was some problem that users
could encounter that was incredibly
frustrating.
It was a little bit of an edge case,
but it was incredibly frustrating.
They'd lose a lot of time and
be really confused.
>> Right.
>> And the testers, the designers
who were working on this project
went to the engineers and said,
hey, this is a big problem!
>> Mm-hm
>> We should fix this.
And the engineers said, that's not a
problem, people don't actually do that.
Right, because engineers are smart.
>> Right.
>> And designers said,
we've seen people do this.
This is a big problem,
we should fix this.
And engineers go, all right,
we'll put it in the backlog,
which means they never
actually get around to it.
And so the designers went back to the
users, and did a bunch more user tests,
and recorded the users and took video
of the users having this problem and
then saying, what just happened?
This is so confusing.
And then strung,
I think it was like 30 to 50 of
these users having this problem in
a row together, sat all the engineers in
a conference room and played the video.
And when you're sitting
In a conference room
watching a video of real people have
real problems with your product,
it's a lot harder to ignore those
problems than if it's just some person
saying they saw somebody maybe
have a problem with this once.
>> Right.
>> So
moral of the story,
take video, show it to people.
It's the most powerful
communication tool you have.
>> Right.
Thank you.
>> Mm-hm.